en plus j'ai un rêve agité cette nuit
j'avais ma deuxième toute la nuit a dit
daniel roux
elle était en elle avait un long manteau
en fourrure elle était mal en dessous
toi et moi j'étais sur ses genoux en
couches et elle me chantait des
comptines
vous embête tout le monde servi je vous
ai écrit directement passé régime a
écrit tout de suite il m'a écrit tout de
suite été réveillé à saisir cinq heures
du matin je vous ai répondu tout de
suite a bien sûr mais vous n'avez jamais
un coup de barre dont la journée un coup
de barre à mine et un quart d'heure
va bien savez aujourd'hui je peux pas
avoir tout bas si j'ai un coup de barre
c'est la france qui s'effondre
non j'ai pas de nom mais ça va là on est
content d'être là il prônerait des coups
de barre ainsi quand votre dernier rêve
érotique vous gagnez le monde
c'était tout à l'heure dans la loge
contenant du passé
[Rires]
c'est pas possible l'impossible réchaud
dans la culture
voyages mais où j'en ai connu un qui
mangent pas de viande ce qu'on aurait pu
faire des grillades bond très important
des rêves si tu verrais positif ou
négatif c'est vrai c'est pas forcément
si ottawa est positif c'est qu'on a
envie d'aller chez carrefour
le plus important reste souvent est ce
qu'il est ces dérives un modèle
honnêtement je ne juge pas ça ne pas
s'attendre à y consentir de la salle
étaient 110 personnes lambert laissé
tomber alors
c'était une partouze avec des rappeurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'art est positif
oui pour c'est une analyse c'est de
l'amour c'est de l'asse de la
non mais c'est vrai je crois pas que
c'était très habile
oui c'est pas les chansons que j'avais
retenu mais en tout cas il serait bon
c'est vrai que je dédie il faut écouter
sur europe 1 j'ai entendu ça si le rêve
est positif ouais ça y'a un mec
internautes et les rêves tu va insister
sur quelle émission europe1 choix vers
11 heures tout comme ça le matin y'a pas
un truc avec julie
cemac vous l'écoutiez c'est radio
je sais qu'il faut j'ai rien à voir là
dedans
alors moi semaine dernière j'ai aussi
fait un rêve érotique merci tu es dans
un blizzard d'ailleurs j'en ai parlé à
mon chéri parce que c'était très bizarre
c'était pas avec lui du coup
finalement elle était tellement fou qu
il a presque ri en fait vous avez eu
dernièrement des les clodettes vous avez
parlé de claude françois y avait les
clos dès lors c'était pas chez moi
et elle disait comme quoi les jeunes
filles l'attendait qui la visent avait
des trucs ensemble et tout est donc moi
le soir j'ai rêvé comme quoi j'attendais
devant la loge de claude françois qui
m'a fait rentrer trop dans l' écho au
moment 2 il avait une petite pile
alcaline
petit fils ex et j'ai rien compris et
moi même je me suis réveillé juste une
pile droit mais dans les télécommandes
quoi enfin de cette nuit c'est tout
après je me suis réveillé
qui avait une pile à la place du nom à
la bouche
françois chanteur tu as envie de coucher
en ce moment avec un chanteur
mais qui chantent l'appellent ses
béquilles gens de ce soir
exactement si vous les choses qu'elle
l'énergie
l'énergie aie a rejoué vivant
sympathique bertrand
et chatons chien combrit de rêve
son chien compris la rigolade ne vais
pas raconter si vous voulez qu'on casse
ambiance pourquoi oui oui bah cassady
racontez-nous votre elle
[Applaudissements]
sait faire la guerre aux tic
je rappelle sam amick vous faites la
télé ça va je rentrais chez moi et en
fait madame coucher avec un homme voyez
que je voyais de dos c'est par cet homme
je vous jure que c'est vrai et je vous
dis je n'invente pas c'était comme
c'était vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai été très embêté parce que je ne
sais pas trop quoi vous dire en fait
déjà débat
notoriété c'est quelque chose je vais en
fonction que je vous ferai les choses
mises à mathieu tu es là je lèverai pas
dire plantations à ses parts à envie de
coucher avec cyrille maret du tout pas
du tout quand un rêve négatif donc de
rêve c'était qu'au cul ouais ça veut
dire que tu as toi-même entendant une
propre culpabilité par rapport à ton cou
à ce
que ça veut dire que je ne s'est pas
trompé euros ou quelque chose
me dit justement vous avez dit un mot
tous les instants cook mais bien entendu
comme les pyramides
quels sont les regards elle peut faire
quand on est on sait que
le team daffix
moi j'ai reproduit même rêve depuis un
moment
c'est avec vous c'est toujours le même
rêve dont j'ai parlé une fois ici et
m'inquiète un peu de cette année
là je suis pas sûr on est dans un champ
de blé ah ouais moi je doublais de
l'argent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le blé est la céréale
je suis allergique au blé donc mon
écoulant courant
l'arrêté que nous avons c'est que nous
courons tous les deux sous le soleil
dans le champ de blé totalement nue
je fais ce régulièrement depuis un
moment et je sais pas quoi correspond
non elle correspond que tu vas lit dans
la chambre et tout seul